welcome to Baywatch I'm asking everybody
today I can't believe you to do this to
do things in slow mode do something in
slow-mo I was okay you're gonna suck pop
in slow-motion slow-motion wings I'm
questioning my life right now that was
the way to us
I wrote a guy who directed the pilot of
the original show and within minutes got
an email of which slow-mo to work and
what surface boobs are Turkish boobs if
you shoot at the wrong speed things
don't go just up and down they go every
which way I want to know the most they
watched cheesy over-the-top thing about
you self-tanner I live for the
self-tanner you see don't do this brain
with the whole Oh get it ain't nobody
got time for that and it up like rotten
your sweat pants all day I ain't your
life all about a good lash extension I
was not blessed with long beautiful
lashes so I'm like sighs yep guy
probably makes my fake tits you said
that this character is just like you
because he's got a jury sense of humor
now I'm seeing it a little bit how house
centipedes my sense of humor I had when
I was 16 he's still the same - I love
all the tag lines in this movie that you
guys have been putting out on social
media my favorite is that you guys are
the dysfunctional r-rated Avengers of
the beach yeah is that your favorite it
is my favorite I'm and that's mine I'm
gonna dare ask you yes Irish adventure
are you I have to be an amalgamation I
would have to say I'm a little bit of
Ironman a little bit of for a little bit
of Hulk a little bit of Black Widow I
love it did lips touch with Dwayne in
this movie there was it looks like a
kiss I don't know if you guys actually
heard they did yeah what it looks like
what's Thicke angel mix with cake angels
angels
yeah I think kids can but I received
mouth-to-mouth from him on San Andreas
yeah every surgery every time doing my
kiss it's like yeah I feel butterflies
happened
yeah it's trivial a Nana's training
begins at 600 love you TV people your
refrigerator very watch we [ __ ]
[Music]
you